what we're going to do in this video is
talk a little bit more about federal
powers versus state powers and as we've
mentioned in other videos this is a very
relevant topic because even today you'll
have supreme court decisions being
decided based on citing different parts
of the constitution or various
amendments that seem to give one power
another more to the federal government
or to the state government another
important appreciation is the balance of
power or the shifts of power between
federal and state it has historically
changed over time so it isn't this fixed
thing
so in a previous video we talked about
the enumerated powers that the
constitution gives the federal
government
in particular
we have talked about the commerce clause
that allows the federal government to
regulate commerce among the several
states which has turned out to be a much
farther reaching power than maybe the
drafters of the constitution intended
and then the thing that really gives
power to even the enumerated powers is
the necessary and proper clause to make
all laws which shall be necessary and
proper for carrying into execution the
foregoing powers and so this is what we
talk about this necessary and proper
clause creates a lot of implied powers
so you can imagine this isn't the
necessary and proper clause is not
something that made the anti-federalists
very happy they were worried about kind
of power grabs by the federal government
and so you have the bill of rights which
are the first ten amendments and the
ninth and tenth amendment in particular
are anti-federalists attempt to
limit the federal government's power so
the ninth amendment says the enumeration
in the constitution of certain rights
shall not be construed to deny or
disparage others retained by the people
and even more important the 10th
amendment and this is really speaking to
federal versus state powers the powers
not delegated to the united states by
the constitution so not delegated to the
federal government nor prohibited by it
the federal government to the states are
reserved to the states respectively or
to the people and so you could view this
as reserved powers for the states it's
an anti-federalist attempt to say hey
you know the federal government can't
just do whatever it wants it's trying to
put a little bit of a check on the
necessary and proper clause so if you
fast forward to the period right after
the civil war you have the 13th
amendment which bans slavery and then
you have the 14th amendment which is
trying to bring slaves into society
allow them to be citizens not just them
but their descendants and this is in
direct contradiction of the 1857 dred
scott decision that we'll talk about in
other videos where the us supreme court
ruled that slaves and their descendants
are not considered american citizens and
so they don't have a right to petition
the government but the 14th amendment
says all persons born or naturalized in
the united states and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof
are citizens of the united states and of
the state wherein they reside
no state shall make or enforce any law
and so this is actually putting
constrains on states and so as we'll see
even though this is in the context of
the post-civil war era because it's
putting constraints on states this is
one of the amendments that's often cited
that puts more power in the hands of the
federal government
no state shall make or enforce any law
which shall abridge the privileges or
immunities of citizens of the united
states nor shall any state deprive any
person of life liberty or property
without due process of law
nor deny to any person within its
jurisdiction the equal protection of the
laws the 14th amendment has been very
relevant in some very current debates
this notion of that in any state no
state can deprive any person of life
liberty or property without due process
of law this is often known as the due
process clause and it's this idea that
no state can really strip away some of
the rights that might be articulated and
say the bill of rights
nor deny to any person within its
jurisdiction the equal protection of the
laws this is often known as the equal
protection clause
this is
you could view as a protection against
some form of discrimination
and so even in very current debates
around things like abortion or same-sex
marriage
much of the debate will center around
the 14th amendment